après plus de deux heures d'attentes
sous un abribus cette jeune maman ils
sont amis sont enfin prise en charge par
une navette gratuite de la ville de
schoelcher un vrai répit pour eux
d'ailleurs et il n'y croyais
pratiquement plus des fois c'est que
vous trouvez ça s'est amené à ce que la
personne a freiné par un bon geste qu'on
n'a pas assez pour le plus mauvais parce
qu'ils font ils ne font pas vraiment
bizarre mais bon si aujourd'hui le love
puisque moi j'avais des besoins mais bon
c'est pas comme si je vois ça tous les
jours je ne vois pas non
le terminus de la navette c'est ici sous
cet abribus proche de la rocade à
madiana où se retrouvent des usagers
chéroy privées transporte depuis des
mois c'est vraiment vraiment calvé a
vraiment embêtant il faut que ça cesse
j'ai une bonne dose de marange rouge au
tombeau
le jeune pour lui tout sauf que le maire
de chelles cher n'a strictement rien à
voir avec l'absence de bus dans sa
commune bien au contraire
face à cette situation est lui aussi
très en colère alors si dans un premier
temps il compte sur la solidarité de
certains transporteurs pour atténuer la
souffrance de ses administrés il
pourrait bien aller plus loin
sachant tout cas toute la détermination
qui celle des habitants tchétchènes
david le chef cheikh pour qu'on puisse
trouver un fait en sorte de mettre un
terme à une situation qui n'a que trop
duré ceci étant en gardant le calme qui
est le nôtre comme l'accoutumée nous
privilégierons toutes les forces les
possibles les voir comment dire de
conciliation mais nous seront utilisés
aussi niveau judiciaire
si seulement la mairie de chelles chers
amis de ses navettes à la disposition de
ses administrés les plus fragiles et les
plus isolés
elles prennent en charge une trentaine
de personnes en moyenne par semaine pour
tous les autres c'est encore le système
d